I decree that Alex Russo is officially
the Russo family wizard we're so glad
you got your Wizarding powers Alex you
definitely deserve them and so did
Justin it's pretty great that both of
you got to be wizards and Max really is
a great fit for the sub shop what are
you and your family up to these days you
save the world from your evil twin so we
guess everything else has been pretty
easy compared to that we never get tired
of watching you and your brothers learn
magic but we've noticed a few things
that we miss the first time around
Wizards of Waverly Place is one of the
most popular Disney Channel shows ever
but it's not without its plot holes and
mistakes keep watching for 10 huge
mistakes you totally miss in the hit
show a wolffish mistake Wizards aren't
the only supernatural people in Wizards
of Waverly Place there are several times
that we see werewolves in the show one
episode in particular is called V
werewolf justin meets a girl on whiz
face the magical social media but she's
a werewolf he really likes this girl a
lot but when these two finally lock lips
something unexpected happens
Justin turns into a werewolf according
to the show just a smooch with a
werewolf is enough to turn someone they
don't even have to bite them under a
full moon like most werewolf lore but
here's where the show messes up in
season 3 Alex dates Maison he is also a
werewolf when these two smooch Alex
doesn't turn into a werewolf
that is a huge pothole it doesn't make
sense for something to be true for one
werewolf and not the other there's a lot
that doesn't add up with this storyline
it's like the writers change their minds
later on but fail to provide an
explanation accidental costume change B
werewolf is the source of another major
mistake and they thought we wouldn't
notice sometimes shows have continuity
errors that's when certain facts don't
continue throughout the entire series it
could be a major plot point like the
werewolf issue it could also be a
mistake in costumes or set designs we
aren't quite sure how this mistake
happened though for most of Justin's
date with Isabella he is wearing a
checkered shirt but in
seeing his shirt changes in the park he
is wearing a checkered shirt then he
goes back to his house he appears to
change shirts as he walks around the
couch after finding out he's going to be
a werewolf
all of a sudden his shirt is striped
we're pretty sure locking lips with the
werewolf doesn't change your shirt
then his shirt is back to being
checkered it's easy to miss but once you
notice it you can't unsee it we aren't
sure what happened in the wardrobe room
for that scene that's not Alex TV shows
often used stunt doubles for various
scenes these people are trained to act
out physically taxing scenes that actors
could get hurt filming it's also useful
when an actor needs to fight themselves
for a storyline that's exactly what
happened in the TV movie the Wizards
return Alex vs. Alex Dominic it's over
you're not gonna take over the world
because I'm here to save it again
Alex accidentally created an evil twin
and she had to fight herself to keep
evil Alex from destroying the world
there are a lot of fight scenes so Alex
obviously needed a stunt double or two
but the show didn't do a great job at
covering the face of the stunt double
check out this scene of Alex doing a
backflip that is clearly not Alex's face
it's not even a girl it's a man doing
the backflip the show made a similar
mistake in wizards vs. werewolves we can
see Justin's stunt doubles face and he
really looks nothing like Justin next
time you watch Wizards of Waverly Place
see if you can find all the times a
stunt double showed up how many legs
another continuity mistake happens with
the emergency wizards they're basically
wizard cops one of them is a goblin we
don't know his name because it's
apparently impossible for humans to
pronounce the emergency wizards show up
the first time in Alex's choice Justin
and Max send out prank mail to relay
that they are in a magical emergency as
a goblin he has some strange features
his face definitely isn't human and in
Alex's Choice he has more than two legs
there are at least three and some fans
have spotted four but the extra legs
aren't the problem in this episode the
problem is they disappear in later
episodes
the emergency Wizards come back in
Harper knows that's the episode where
Harper finds out that the Russos are
Wizards in this episode the goblin cop
only has two legs Andy's wearing slacks
over his two legs he wasn't in the first
episode this is a pretty sneaky mistake
we wonder why they decided to get rid of
his extra legs lock it up
Alex's choice has another continuity
error and this time it happens within
less than a minute we know that
sometimes scenes are shot out of order
so when the show is edited together
mistakes are bound to happen
Theresa Russo is tired of Justin and Max
fighting they make a big deal about how
their lair is locked but then Theresa
pulls a key down from the wall she sends
them into the lair we can see her
debating on whether or not to lock the
boys inside there but she decides not to
she sets the lock on the counter a few
seconds later alex comes in upset about
gigi we can see that the lock is back on
the door behind them considering that
the lock is a major part of the
storyline in the episode that's a pretty
big mistake we can't believe it was
overlooked did you notice that error you
don't need to cast a spell for more
great videos about your favorite Disney
Channel shows just click the red button
to subscribe to the thing be sure to
turn on notifications for YouTube in
your phone settings so you never miss
another video
the vanishing Apple honestly we aren't
sure what was happening in Alex's choice
fans have pointed out more errors from
this episode than any other another
continuity mistake happens later in the
episode and it's similar to the issue
with the lock Alex and Harper get
invited to Gigi's tea party but it's
really a joke by Gigi to humiliate
Harper Alex tries to convince Harper not
to go but Harper doesn't believe Alex
they're talking in front of a fruit
stand Harper is practicing handling
apples before the tea party because
she's so clumsy she knocks down all the
apples except for one but in the next
shot the Apple that stayed in place was
gone a few shots later that Apple is
back we're so confused where did the
Apple go this must have been shot in
several takes but they didn't bother to
keep the apple in place
do you love finding all the mistakes on
TV
chose keep watching to find out the
biggest mistake in Wizards of Waverly
Place Olive transfers it seems like plot
holes are a regular occurrence on a lot
of Disney Channel shows and Wizards of
Waverly Place is no exception it's hard
to keep track of details when there are
so many episodes and each episode
usually has two or three storylines but
this plot hole seems like a pretty big
thing to miss in the season 3 episode
the good the bad and the alux we learn
about the Hall of transfers this is
apparently where powers get transferred
to the family wizard
Stevie's brother was supposed to be the
family wizard but he left the Hall of
transfers before he could get his powers
it's a huge piece of information about
how the magic works in Wizarding
families but then in season 4 the Russos
finally figure out who gets their powers
they never go to the Hall of transfers
instead the powers are granted by the
headmaster we're so confused we've
really expected there to be a big scene
at the Hall of transfers what happened
to this storyline if something changed
in the magical world the show certainly
didn't let the audience know macing the
student has there ever been a Disney
Channel couple that went through as much
as Alex and Mason we don't think so
together they fought curses and vampires
they found true love's necklace and they
almost had to part ways forever when
Mason became a permanent wolf but true
love triumphs and they eventually ended
up together however there is a big plot
hole with Mason's storyline the first
time Alex meets him he is a new student
in her art class there's a whole episode
about it because she accidentally
insults his painting but after that
episode they're never seen in school
together again they never mentioned
Mason being at school either how did
this major plot hole slip past the
show's creators and that's not even the
biggest part of the mistake
Mason is over 300 years old according to
later episodes why is he a student at
school at all and he's an accomplished
artist he really didn't need to be in
art class missing rope
we love finding small continuity errors
and TV episodes and the
a really sneaky one in the episode art
museum Peas
you probably remember this episode
because it's one of the funniest Alex
tries to make her art history assignment
easier by bringing the paintings to life
she wants to ask them questions but
afterward they don't want to go back in
their frames she tries to put them back
but she doesn't know where they go
thankfully Justin lends her a helping
hand in order to bring them to life Alex
puts a rope around the door handles that
way no one can get in and see the
paintings in motion but later the Rope
disappears
it's only for a split second before a
commercial break when the show comes
back the paintings are trying to leave
and the rope
is back on the door where did it go
before and how did it get back we have
so many questions it seems like a pretty
big thing to overlook Miranda's mistake
do you remember Miranda she was the goth
girl who Justin dated for a while she
first appeared in the second episode of
the series first kiss in this episode we
find out that they've been dating for a
few weeks
Justin keeps trying to finally lock lips
with this pretty girl but Miranda
appears again a few episodes later
episode 10 is called pop me and we both
go down this is the episode where Justin
gets a huge talking zit Grandes
introduced as a brand new student in
this episode and it is supposed to be
the first time Justin meet sir
wait what it's only been a few episodes
we totally remember Miranda from before
there's a good chance that these
episodes were aired out of order but
that is still a huge mistake did they
think the audience wouldn't notice
we were totally confused and thought we
were going crazy when Miranda appeared
as a new student but plenty of fans have
wondered about this too who was your
favorite wizard of waverly place let us
know in the comments thanks for watching
give this video a big thumbs up if you
love Wizards of Waverly Place see you
next time on the things